Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 272. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich versuche schon seit Jahren durch diese Sendung zu führen. Für mich ist das heute aber eine Premiere, weil meistens ist es so, dass es Dinge gibt, die unsere digitale Welt prägen, bereichern, existent sind und dann tritt jemand dagegen und dann sind die kaputt. Aber es gibt sie zumindest. Und jetzt ist es zumindest, also in meiner Erinnerung das erste Mal, dass etwas im Moment des Erscheinens auch schon wieder verschwindet. Worüber reden wir heute? Wir reden heute über die E-Identität oder den E-Führerschein oder digitale Identität im weitesten Sinne, im staatlichen vor allem. Dazu heiße ich herzlich willkommen einerseits Karl Fabian Lübcke, hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo.
Auch Fluepke genannt und Christian Carlo, hallo und guten Tag.
Ihr seid beide damit beschäftigt, manchmal gegen Dinge zu treten, digitale Sachen zu zerforschen und seid heute hier um uns ein bisschen näher zu erklären, was eigentlich passiert ist. Und ich würde gerne sozusagen aus meiner Perspektive am Anfang anfangen, weil es wirklich so war, ich also wache quasi auf, schaue in meinen Social Media Stream, sehe, aha, es gibt anscheinend jetzt, so vermelden zumindest einige Medien einen elektronischen Führerschein, der irgendwie auf dem Smartphone abgespeichert kann. Und gefühlt im selben Moment kommt die nächste Nachricht, ach nee, gibt es doch nicht. Das ist so kaputt, dass es jetzt wieder weg ist. Ich glaube, in Wirklichkeit war das ein bisschen anders. Und vielleicht sozusagen bis noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit zwischen diesen beiden Sachen vergangen. Aber ich war tatsächlich, obwohl ich mich in diesem Thema relativ gut bewandert, fühle ich mich ein bisschen überrascht, elektronischer Führerschein im Smartphone. Das war mir völlig entgangen, dass überhaupt daran gearbeitet wird. Könntet ihr kurz erklären, wer da welchen Plan hatte und seit wann das Ganze schon im Gange ist?
Ja, also das Ganze ist hervorgegangen aus drei Projekten vom Bundeswirtschaftsministerium. Dort gibt es drei Förderprojekte, das sogenannte Ökosystem digitale Identitäten. Und da hat man beschlossen, wir forschen jetzt mal daran, wie kriegt man halt moderne digitale Identitäten in Deutschland abgebildet. Das Ganze hat noch einen Hintergrund. In Europa hat man sich darauf verständigt, eine European Blockchain Services Infrastructure zu bauen. Und so greift das Ganze einander. Die EU hat dort auch gesagt, dass sie eine EU Digital ID ausbringen will für ganz Europa und dass jeder Mitgliedstaat dementsprechend eine Wallet auch zur Verfügung stellen soll. Und das war so der erste Versuch, was zu bauen. Und das Bundeskanzleramt hat also hier noch ein extra Projekt, sozusagen, nach oben gezogen. Das war diese ID Wallet, mit der man dann gesagt hat, okay, das Ding fuschen wir jetzt ganz nach vorne. Da fing an mit Hotelcheck-in und wir bringen jetzt den Personalausweis in diese Wallet mit rein. Und dann nehmen wir noch den Führerschein mit hinzu. Und das war so der Moment, den du dann mitbekommen hast.
Okay, okay, also, da waren schon wieder sehr viele Fachworte drin. Ich versuche mal zusammenzufassen an dieser Stelle schon. Die Idee war, man baut eine App für Smartphone, wo digitale Identitäten, die tatsächlich sozusagen von Behörden relevant sind, also Führerschein oder Personalausweis sogar, also in einer Smartphone-App. Das Ganze ist sozusagen das Vorzeigeprojekt für eine Entwicklung auf EU-Ebene, wo nämlich beschlossen wurde, unsere Identitäten sollen digital verwaltet werden können. Und es spielt auch eine Rolle dabei, dass das mittels Blockchain gemacht werden soll.
Ja, so zumindest auch der Tonus auf EU-Ebene.
Okay, Blockchain werden wir wahrscheinlich in dieser Sendung nicht ganz von vorne erklären. Es gibt dazu schon Chaosradios, die wir auch in den Show Notes verlinken. Und wir sprechen nachher mal wahrscheinlich noch genauer darüber, wie sinnvoll das ist. Ich bin ja überhaupt überrascht davon, dass so ein Projekt überhaupt das Licht der Welt erblickt. Aber gut, wie lange ist denn an dieser konkreten App, die dann tatsächlich auch erschienen ist, gearbeitet worden?
Das können wir nicht ganz genauer sagen. Die Esatos war der Meinung, dass sie da schon was vorbereitet hätten.
Das ist die Firma dahinter?
Genau, das war die Firma, die jetzt die ID Wallet gebaut hatte. Eine Tochterunternehmen, die Digital Nappling GmbH, ist dort auch als öffentlicher Erscheinung getreten in den Stores.
Wenn du gerade schnell dabei bist, muss ich fragen, ist das eine wirklich privatwirtschaftliche Firma, die den Auftrag bekommen hat? Oder ist das sozusagen so eine Ministeriumsausgründung oder wird vom Staat gehalten?
Die Digital Nappling ist im April gegründet worden, gehört zu dieser Esatos AG und die sind auch komplett privatwirtschaftlich aufgestellt und haben über Bande diesen Auftrag bekommen. Also wir haben ja inzwischen so rausgehört, dass die Bundestrockerei das irgendwie weiter vergeben hat. Die hat dann einen Rahmenvertrag bedient von einem Systemvertrieb Alexander GmbH und die haben die Esatos ins Spiel gebracht.
Ich fasse zusammen, es gibt mehrere Schritte, über deren Auftrag vergeben wurde, wie die Privatwirtschaft klären soll, dass unsere digitale Identitäten verwaltet werden. Da haben wir schon sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht im Corona damit. Okay, gut, da sollte also was vorbereitet werden. So, jetzt überlege ich mich zur Frage, wie sinnvoll ist die Idee? Vielleicht fragen wir das am Anfang doch mal. Es gibt ja so ganz generelle Vorbehalte manchmal oder Dinge, die man beachten soll, wenn man wichtige Daten im digitalen oder sagen wir mal staatliche Prozesse, behördliche Prozesse im digitalen nachbildet. Das ist immer so ein Spagat zwischen einerseits wünschen wir uns das, weil das viele Dinge einfacher macht, andererseits geht es da halt um irgendwie höchst persönliche Dinge oder auch um sehr relevante Dinge und da muss man halt immer sehr vorsichtig sein. Jetzt mal abgesehen von dem, was jetzt daran kaputt ist oder was da rausgefallen ist, wenn man gegentritt, ist das Konzept, also sind wir schon so weit, dass man sagen kann, also ganz grundsätzlich ist das Konzept, wir verbinden oder wir erlauben es BürgerInnen auf dem Smartphone, ihre digitale Identität zu verwalten. Ist das was, wo man sagt, ja, daran können wir arbeiten, das ist vielleicht realisierbar, oder ist das eher so was wie elektronische Wahlen, wo man sagt, egal wie ihr das macht, das ist ganz generell eine schlechte Idee?
Also das, was Lilith und ich da jetzt angegriffen haben, da können wir gerne gleich das nochmal ein bisschen weiter ausführen. Das ist was in dem Konzept, also wir haben da ein Protokoll, das Teil dieser Self-Sovereign Identity Lösung ist angegriffen. Und damit muss man erstmal festhalten, dass nicht nur irgendwie eine App davon betroffen ist. Wir haben es jetzt an der Lisi App vorgeführt, weil die irgendwie ein bisschen zuverlässiger funktioniert hat als die ID Wallet App von der Esatus. Die war ja auch komplett offline gegangen. Das heißt, wir haben da erstmal sehr konzeptionelle Schwachstellen festgestellt. Ganz grundsätzlich finde ich die Ansprüche, die sie dort stellen, also dass man irgendwie so eine selbstsouveräne Identität hat, dass man irgendwie darüber kontrolliert, wie man seine Daten gibt und was für Daten man irgendwie rausgibt. Das sind natürlich erstmal sehr coole Designziele. Ob die da so erreicht werden können, ist die Frage. Und zum anderen ist natürlich auch die Frage, ob man seine Identität einer App auf einem Telefon anvertrauen möchte. Denn am Ende des Tages vertraut man da natürlich der Platform Security von Android oder iOS. Und deswegen ist ja zum Beispiel der neue Personalausweis, wie wir ihn kennen, da kann CK auch sicher mehr zu erzählen, quasi so eine Smartcard und nicht so ein ganzes Mobile Operating System.
Also wenn ich versuche eine Antwort auf meine Frage zu finden, würdest du sagen, das ist was, das könnte man probieren, aber da muss man schon sehr, sehr, sehr sorgfältig sein, wenn man das macht.
Genau und da sollten dann halt auch entsprechende Leute drauf schauen und das Ganze auditieren. Da sollte das BSI drauf schauen und das sollte halt nicht so ein digitaler Schnellschuss sein, wie wir ihn jetzt hier erlebt haben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich habe schon die Idee, wie die Antworten auf diese Fragen sind, aber dazu kommen wir vielleicht gleich. CK, auch von dir vielleicht nochmal ganz grundsätzlich gefragt, Personalausweis im Smartphone ist das eine gute Idee, die nur an der Umsetzung sozusagen scheitern kann oder am falschen Konzept auch? Oder ist das was, was man generell lassen sollte?
Ja, es gab so einen schönen heißen Artikel, der sagte, der Personalausweis kommt jetzt in drei verschiedenen Varianten aus dem Telefon und das trifft es auch so ungefähr. Es gibt natürlich Wege, das Ganze im Rahmen der technischen Mittel so ordentlich wie möglich zu machen. Das ist zum Beispiel dieses Smart-EID-Thema, was in der originären Variante das Ganze in ein sogenanntes Secure Element speichert. So ein Secure Element ist ein abgesetzter einzelner Kryptochip, der sehr hoch evaluiert ist. Das entspricht ungefähr so dem Chip, den man auch in der Karte drin hat, in der Plastikarte, in dem Ausweis. Und dann habe ich auch ein Sicherheitsniveau, was ich da abbilden kann, was vertretbar ist für so eine ganze Aktion. Insbesondere, weil das Ding getrennt ist von der eigentlichen Haupt-CPU, wo sämtliche Spiele und bei Android auch die Stage-Freitlöcken und was nicht alles durchläuft und auch getrennt ist von der Baseband-CPU, wo man ja auch so im Chaos weiß, dass die ja regelmäßig gerne gehackt werden.
Baseband-CPU, das muss man vielleicht kurz sagen, das ist das Bauteil, was dafür zuständig ist, dass man mit dem Smartphone tatsächlich noch telefonieren kann.
Genau, meistens ist das auch tatsächlich gehackt. Deswegen möchte man eben halt genauso eine Identität in einem getrennten Chip haben. Wir haben deswegen auch so das Sicherheitsmodell ein bisschen verändert, dass man nicht mit einem Geräteentsperrungen da durchkommt, sondern dass man tatsächlich eine Pin bis runter in das Secure Element präsentieren muss, auf einem sicheren Kanal, um das eben halt freizuschalten. So, das ist der eine Weg. Dann hat man gesagt, naja, da erreichen wir ja nicht alle Geräte, wir müssen da eine Software-Variante bauen. Das ist also schon genauso kaputt, weil dann ein geroutetes Gerät oder ein Gerät, was mit einem Trojaner irgendwie angegriffen wird, natürlich auch die Kontrolle dann über das Schüsselmaterial verliert. Das heißt also, man kann dann falsche Identitäten auch erzeugen oder die abziehen. Das gibt das Modell so ein bisschen her an der Stelle. Und bei der Blockchain-Geschichte ist das Ganze noch mal so ein bisschen zum Quadrat.
Das ist mir schon wieder viel zu viel im Detail. Ich wollte erst mal nur wissen, kann man grundsätzlich versuchen, eine digitale Identität zu bauen? Ich höre jetzt so ein bisschen raus, das geht, wenn man nicht nur die Software sozusagen sehr sorgfältig baut, sondern wenn man auch dafür sorgt, dass die Daten, die da gespeichert sind, nicht im, hier dürfen alle drauf zugreifen, Bauteilen abspeichern, wenn es dafür noch mal extra Hardware in den Geräten gibt, die verhindert werden. Und daraus wiederum kann ich auch ableiten, dass du sagst, oder dass ich meine verstanden zu haben, man kann das machen, man muss sich aber wie bei allen digitalen Lösungen darüber im Klaren sein, dass man nur den Aufwand für den Missbrauch erschweren kann, man kann es nie ganz ausschließen.
Ja, ganz ausschließend ist das richtig, aber man versucht das dann wirklich so in 99, Prozentbereich zu treiben, um tatsächlich eben halt möglichst viele Hürden reinzulegen. Und das funktioniert am besten, indem man so an sich element mit der Aufgabe betraut, was dann einfach auch die Zugriffsrechte kontrolliert, wer darf überhaupt was lesen, was geht ja weiter. Da nicht nur der Nutzer sagt, ja, ich möchte jetzt hier interagieren, sondern ich muss ja auch die Gegenseite identifizieren, wer ist das eigentlich und welche Rechte hat derjenige? Was darf der jetzt bekommen?
Die 99%-Figur hatten wir jetzt ja auch schon im Rahmen dieser ID Wallet im Raum. Und da muss man auch einfach mal ganz klar sagen, dass das nicht eine 99%-Lösung ist. Also das ist halt schon beim Anschauen auseinandergefallen. Der Nameserver von ihm zum Beispiel hat dann von Auslängli so ein bisschen den Eindruck gehabt, als hätten die da panisch alle Kabel gezogen.
Okay, was der Nameserver damit zu tun hat, machen wir auch gleich. Aber wir halten mal fest, wir sind 2021 an der Stelle, wo wir sagen, also wenn man wollte, dann könnte man, dann muss man das nur sehr sorgfältig machen. Und das ist aber anscheinend nicht der Fall gewesen, weil man gegengepustet hat und dann ist das Kartenhaus in sich zusammengefallen. Und das würde mich jetzt tatsächlich dann an dieser Stelle im Detail interessieren. Was ist denn eigentlich passiert? Also Fluepke, wenn man sozusagen, wenn man es von außen verfolgt, dann sind die Namen, die da dran stehen, erst mal deiner und der von Lilith Wittmann. Also sie hat einen Artikel veröffentlicht und da steht dann dein Name mit drunter. Was genau ist eigentlich passiert, ist das sozusagen wirklich? Ihr habt die App aufgemacht und dann war sofort klar, das ist kaputt. Oder habt ihr irgendwie Standard-Gegentretprozesse eingeleitet und die waren dann gleich erfolgreich oder so? Wie man auf die Idee kommt, sich das anzugucken, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber was genau ist passiert? Wie seid ihr auf die Sachen gekommen, die da passiert sind?
Ich gebe mal eine kurze Timeline, chronologisch was passiert ist. Lilith und ich sind darauf aufmerksam geworden, dass die Bundesregierung ganz knapp vor der Wahl irgendwie noch ein Prestigedigitalisierungsprojekt online gestellt hat. Das hat natürlich dann die Aufmerksamkeit von uns an sich gezogen. Ich hatte dann zunächst auf die Infrastrukturkomponenten drauf geschaut, weil ich mich mit Infrastrukturdingen recht gut auskenne. Da ist mir zum Beispiel aufgefallen, dass der DNS-Server kaputt war.
Das ist ja auch die Sendung, für die es von vorne verstehen soll. Das heißt, so eine App besteht aus verschiedenen Komponenten. Also andersrum, die App ist nicht nur die App, sondern im Hintergrund werkelt da Infrastruktur. Bevor du erklärst, was du kaputt gemacht hast, kannst du erklären, welche Infrastruktur dahintersteht, die man braucht, um sowas zu betreiben, oder die in dem Fall benutzt wurde?
Genau, die App ist ja auch nur ein Bestandteil in einer größeren SSI-Infrastruktur. Grundsätzlich, wenn man irgendwie eine App betreiben möchte, dann braucht man DNS. DNS hat bestimmt alle schon mal oder viele mal gehört.
Das ist das Telefonbuch des Internets.
Genau, das ist das Domain Name System. Und es wird halt dafür benutzt, um irgendwie Hausnamen, sowas wie CCC.de, auf eine IP-Adresse aufzulösen. Und normalerweise funktioniert das so, dass ich zu dem Nameserver vom CCC gehe und sage, hallo, was ist denn die IP-Adresse von CCC.de? Und dann kriege ich eine Antwort und dann kann ich mit dem Server vom CCC unter der IP-Adresse eine Verbindung aufbauen und hier die Webseite runterladen und anzeigen lassen. Jetzt hier bei dem Nameserver war es allerdings so, dass ich zu dem hingehen konnte und sagen konnte, sag mir mal alles, was du zu esatus.com weißt. Und dann habe ich quasi das gesamte Zone-File von dem Nameserver erhalten, wo auch die gesamten Subdomains und alles mit drin stand. Das sind erstmal keine Geheiminformationen oder so, aber das bringt mir als Angreifer natürlich trotzdem was, weil ich kann dann sehen, was für Subdomains gibt es. Ich könnte versuchen, aus den Subdomains irgendwelche, also die Subdomains, die dahinterliegt sind, könnte ich probieren herauszufinden, was für Services sie da betreiben. Oder wo ich irgendwie mal als nächstes genauer nachschauen kann, kann ja sein, dass da noch irgendwelche Testsysteme oder sowas drin liegt, die dann vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen schlechter abgesichert sind. Und normalerweise schaltet man deswegen so diese Zone-Transfers aus. Und dann muss man die Subdomain halt erraten, um da dran zu kommen, was halt sehr aufwendig sein kann. Und dann müssen wir halt irgendwie so alle möglichen Subdomains durchprobieren.
Das heißt, das ist, also das ist sagen, also A, was verstehe ich jetzt? Das ist relativ unaufwendig, das zu machen. Und B, ist es aber auch so eher best practice, also sinnvollerweise lässt man das sich anzeigen. Das ist aber an sich noch keine harte Sicherheitslücke.
Richtig, genau. Also das ist erst mal keine Sicherheitslücke. Ich selber habe Sonntransfer es auch eingeschaltet, weil ich finde, dass das DNS-Lust da drin steht, ist kein Geheimnis. Interessanter wird die ganze Nummer deswegen, weil sie dort noch ein paar Karteileichen drin liegen hatten. Hanno Berg hatte das vorgeführt, dass man da eine Subdomain übernehmen konnte. Das heißt, wir hatten dann hinterher die Kontrolle über eine Webseite, wo oben drüber irgendwas, esatus.com war es, glaube ich, drin stand. Das ist natürlich ein Subdomain-Takeover, der ist ein bisschen kritischer als einfach nur ein Zone-File zu sehen. Denn dann kann man natürlich unter dieser Webseite probieren irgendwelche Cookies zu stehlen. Das ist ja die gleiche Parent-Domain, das ist ja beides esatus.com. Dann könnte ich probieren irgendwie Cookies von einer anderen Webseite, die auch unter esatus.com läuft, irgendwie zu stehlen. Das haben wir aber nicht gemacht. Wir haben einfach nur folgeführt, man kann ein Subdomain-Takeover machen. Ich kann auch gerne noch mal erklären, was das genau ist.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, zum Verständnis, es gibt ccc.de. Und dann gibt es möglicherweise diese Subdomains, also sowas wie datenschleuder.ccc.de. Ich weiß nicht, ob es sie wirklich gibt. Ich ziehe mir jetzt nur Beispiele aus dem Ärmel, wo man alle Ausgaben der Datenschleuder sehen kann. Und ihr, du sagst jetzt sozusagen, was ihr gemacht habt, um beim Beispiel zu bleiben, ist, ihr konntet dem System sagen, ach, übrigens, gegentreten.ccc.de ist auch eine Domain. Und die kontrollieren wir. Und dann...
Nicht ganz. Also, wir konnten auf dem System keine Einträge verändern oder manipulieren. Aber was wir konnten, ist... Oder ich hol da mal vielleicht anders aus. Man stellt sich vor, der Chaos Computer Club hat jetzt irgendwie ein cooles, hippes Digitalisierungsprojekt. Und das gibt jetzt alles in die Cloud.ccc.de. Und da haben wir dann ein C-Name eingetragen. Also, so eine Referenz ist das. Da steht dann drin, schau mal bei ccc.asia.microsoft.com nach. Dieser C-Name ist quasi ein Eintrag, den kann man ins DNS reinschreiben. Und das heißt, irgendwie für diese Subdomain musst du mal diesen anderen Namen nachschauen. Das macht man normalerweise so, zum Beispiel für solche Cloud-Instanzen, damit Microsoft die dahinter liegende IP-Adresse verwalten kann. Das heißt, wenn sie da mal irgendwie irgendwas in ihrer Infrastruktur umbauen, meine VM, die ich irgendwie da bei Microsoft habe, irgendwie von A nach B verschieben, dass die hinterher immer noch über den gleichen DNS-Namen erreichbar ist, dafür setze ich halt in mein DNS so ein C-Name rein.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt zu kleinteilig werde, aber das ist also so eine Art Weiterleitung. Ich kontrolliere die Domain-Namen und benutze aber sozusagen Infrastruktur, die mein anderer Anbieter zur Verfügung stellt und mache sozusagen so eine Art Weiterleitung, damit der Anbieter, der mir die Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stellt, das halt so oder so ändern kann, ohne dass ich jedes Mal an meinen DNS-Eintrag gehen muss.
Und das ist auch alles schick und schön soweit. Das Problem ist bloß, dass wenn es dann irgendwie diese Domain bei Microsoft nicht mehr gibt, weil die VM irgendwie gelöscht wurde oder so, dann kann ich...
Entschuldigung, VMs sind virtuelle Maschinen. Das heißt, man hat keine eigene Hardware, keinen Rechner, der Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stellt. Sondern das wird auch irgendwie anders abgebildet, da muss man sich aber nicht selber darum kümmern.
Das heißt, die haben sich da wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Maschinen geklickt, um da irgendwelche Tests oder sowas auszuführen. Und haben die dann irgendwann gelöscht. Aber den Eintrag in ihrem eigenen DNS nicht gelöscht. Und dann war es halt möglich, einfach sich bei Microsoft in den Account zu klicken. Und dann konnte man sich halt in der entsprechenden Region einen entsprechenden Namen vergeben. Und dann hat plötzlich eine Subdomain von der esatus.com auf eine von mir kontrollierte Instanz gezeigt. Und dann konnte ich da was auch immer ausleihen.
Das könnte man vielleicht tatsächlich mit dem Telefonbuch Beispiel ganz gut erklären. Also im Telefonbuch steht meine Nummer. Und meine Nummer ist aber gar kein eigenes Telefon, sondern ist eine Weiterleitung auf eine andere Nummer. Und diese andere Nummer, die wird irgendwann frei. Und dann kralle ich mir die. Das heißt, wenn dann jemand im Telefonbuch nachschlägt und mich anruft, ruft er die kontrollierte Nummer, die mittlerweile fremdkontrollierte Nummer an.
Und du glaubst halt, währenddessen irgendwie es mit der Esatus zu tun zu haben.
Und das erlaubt es nicht nur, dass ihr dritten Gegenüber vortäuschen könnt, ihr seid Esatus oder ihr wäret Esatus, sondern ihr habt dann auch dadurch Zugriff auf deren Systeme oder Daten?
Das nicht. Wir kontrollieren halt einfach nur ein Subdomain. Also könnten dann halt auf irgendwas Subdomain Esatus halt irgendwas unterlegen und da probieren irgendwie Cookies zu stehlen.
Was meinst du, das hast du vorhin schon mal gesagt, was meinst du mit Cookies Stehlen?
Naja, Browser haben so eine Sicherheitsfeature, dass sie halt Cookies nur an die gleiche Domain verschicken. Das kann man unterschiedlich konfigurieren. Es kommt ein bisschen darauf an, wie die Cookies gesetzt werden. Aber es ist am Ende auch nicht ganz interessant, weil das kein Angriff ist, den wir durchgeführt oder vorgeführt haben. Aber prinzipiell könnte man eventuell dort Sessions oder angemeldete Benutzeraccounts stehlen.
Okay, also das heißt, das, was du da gefunden hast, durch einfaches Angucken, ist nichts, was in dem konkreten Fall gefährlich ist erst mal, was aber schon mal Zweifel aufkommen lässt, wie gründlich da der Job der Sicherheit gemacht wurde.
Ganz richtig. Also da stellen sich halt schon so ein bisschen die Fragen, wie die da ihre IT Operations machen. Nicht zuletzt, weil auch auf dem Name Server ein Datenbank-Port Richtung Internet exposed war. Das ist auch etwas, was man so normalerweise eher nicht macht, eine Datenbank Richtung Internet zu exponieren. Da war kein Zugriff möglich. Da hätte man sich mit einem Passwort und einem Benutzernamen irgendwie anmelden müssen. Natürlich liegt die Vermutung nahe, dass das die Datenbank ist, in der die ganzen Informationen vom DNS drin liegen. Das ist jetzt aber Spekulation. Da hätte man dann angreifen können, um zu gucken, ob man das DNS selber manipuliert bekommt. Das wäre aber natürlich auch verboten. Deswegen haben wir das noch nicht gemacht.
Stopp, ich muss noch eine Abzweigung nehmen. Das hat CK auch schon verwendet. Du hast es ja schon abgekürzt. SSI, Selbstsouveränidentität. Das scheint in diesem Fall, über dem wir gerade reden, ein wichtiges Konzept zu sein. Könnt ihr vielleicht kurz erklären, weil das ja immer wieder vorkommt, was damit gemeint ist?
Ja, soll ich mal anfangen? Also das Konzept einer Selbstsouveränidentität ist schon älter. Das gibt es schon lange, bevor das Ganze zusammen mit Blockchain verrührt worden ist. Und die Idee dahinter ist, dass diese Identität bei mir liegt. Also im Gegensatz zu einer Identität, die zum Beispiel in einer zentralen Datenbank liegt. Dann stellt man sich mal vor, früher UNIX-Systeme oder heute in vielen Unternehmen Active Directory. Da habe ich einen Eintrag zu meinem Nutzernamen. Da steht drin, wie ich heiße, was weiß ich, welche Telefonnummer ich vielleicht habe, E-Mail-Adresse, wie meine Visitenkartenbezeichnung ist, weiß der Geier was. Und das ist eine zentrale Identität, wo ich mich nur authentisiere mit meinem Nutzernamen. Ich kenne das Passwort dazu. Und dann kann die halt weiterverwendet werden im Kontext. Und wenn ich das Ganze aber selbst zu verreden haben möchte, heißt das, dass die halt bei mir gespeichert ist. Beim Ausweis ist es zum Beispiel so, die Daten stehen in dem Chip. Und das nächste ist, dass ich ein dezentrales System habe. Das heißt, es gibt kein Mediator oder ein zentrales System, was halt nur mit meiner eigenen Identität reden kann. Und das dann für Dritte zur Verfügung stellt. Sondern ich kann selber entscheiden, da ist ein Dritter. Dem gegenüber möchte ich mich jetzt irgendwie zu erkennen geben. Und das ist der nächste Punkt der Souveränität. Ich entscheide das an der Stelle. Ich habe zwar hinten dran eine Infrastruktur, die mir irgendwie definiert, was für Protokolle gibt es da zum Beispiel. Oder wie identifiziert sich auch so ein Dritter mir gegenüber, dass ich weiß, aha, das ist jetzt mal nicht wegen die Stadt Dortmund und nicht etwa irgendjemand anders, sondern Angreifer. Und der nächste ganz wichtige Punkt, der auch bei der EU hoch gehandelt worden ist, ist, dass ich einzeln selektieren kann, welche Attribute meiner Identität ich preisgebe. Das wird gerne untergliedert in die Vornamen, die Nachnamen, den Geburtsnamen, Geburtsort, Geburtsdatum, eventuell auch nur eine Altersverifikation und auch die Adresse, an der ich wohne. Weil nicht immer braucht man alle Informationen über mich. Und dieses Freie selber entscheiden, zu sehen, welche Daten fragt jemand an. Und dann ja, ich möchte dir das sagen, oder nein, ich möchte es dir nicht sagen. Das ist auch ein Punkt der Souveränität. Das sind die einfachsten Grundprinzipien dabei. Und selbst wenn jetzt eine Infrastruktur irgendwie flöten geht oder eine Microsoft plötzlich beschließt, ja, wir schmeißen die Accounts weg, dann ist meine Identität, weil sie selbstsouverän ist, immer noch bei mir und immer noch vorhanden. Das kann mich keiner zentral löschen. Das ist auch so der Kontrastpunkt zu einer Google, Facebook, Amazon etc. Wenn ich da irgendwelche Identitäten habe und die dann der Meinung sind, ja, wir sperren dich jetzt, dann ist die weg.
Das heißt, die Daten liegen immer bei mir. Und das System stellt aber sicher, dass wenn die Informationen ausgetauscht werden, dass alle Teilnehmerinnen erkennen können, die Daten, die da ausgetauscht werden, sind richtig. Also ich darf entscheiden, wer von mir was weiß. Aber wenn ich was übermittele, kann das System sozusagen so okay, die Informationen, die mir da gerade übermittelt werden, die sind Teil einer korrekten Identität.
Genau, richtig.
Und umgedreht auch sozusagen, wenn ich jemandem was zeige, soll ich immer wissen können, dem ich da was zeige, A darf das sehen und B ich weiß, wer das ist.
Und vielleicht noch kurz, wie das funktioniert, stellt man sich einfach einen Geldschein vor. Ein Geldschein hat Sicherheitsmerkmale. Also so Mikroschrift, dann diese UV-Schnipselchen, die da drin sind, ein Wasserzeichen und so. Und das weist diesen Geldschein als echt aus. Und dann gucke ich nächstes Mal das ganz drauf, ist das jetzt ein 20-Euro-Schein, ist das ein 50-Euro-Schein, dann hat der auch noch eine Seriennummer. Und diese Informationen sind deswegen vertrauenswertig, weil der Träger, sozusagen der Container der ganzen Sache, der ist echt. Und so kann ich das dann auswählen. Möchte ich jetzt nur den Betrag nennen oder möchte ich vielleicht auch die Seriennummer mit dem Geldschein nennen? Genau so kann man sich das mit den DT auch vorstellen.
Okay, das heißt für mich, und dann würde ich jetzt wieder sozusagen zur Timeline zurückkehren, das heißt für mich also, das System soll ein System sein, wo jeder einzelne Nutzer in die Kontrolle über ihre Daten hat, das aber in sich sozusagen, wir haben es gesagt, 100%ige Sicherheit gibt es nicht, das in sich aber so sorgfältig gebaut ist, dass eben genau dieser Anspruch, der Selbstsouveränidentität weitestgehend ermöglicht ist. Das ist das erste Beispiel, was Fluepke gerade erzählt hat, schon ein Anzeichen dafür, dass man, also das hat nichts praktisch damit zu tun, aber man könnte Bedenken haben, wenn die überall so nicht sorgfältig arbeiten wie hier, dass es vielleicht passieren könnte. Was war der nächste Schritt?
Genau, vielleicht erst mal noch ganz kurz, das, was sie da als Designziel hatten mit dieser selbstsouveränen Identität, das ist natürlich total super. Was dann als Nächstes passiert ist, naja, sie haben den DNS-Server panisch vom Internet genommen, der ist offline gegangen. Und ab dem Zeitpunkt stimmt natürlich auch die Ausrede des Herstellers nicht mehr, dass die App wegen zu viel Belastung oder wegen so einer Überlastsituation offline gegangen sei. Sondern ab dem Zeitpunkt konnte die App halt nicht mehr funktionieren, weil eben das DNS nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Warte mal, also, ihr habt was gefunden, was sozusagen nicht best practice war, aber auch nicht wirklich gefährlich. Richtig. Und die Antwort war, wir nehmen das System vom Strom.
Ja, also sie haben den Server erstmal so für 10-20 Minuten offline genommen. Das war so nach 2-3 Stunden. Und da hat dann wahrscheinlich irgendein wachgeklingelter Atem irgendwie panisch versucht, das auszuschalten, dieses Feature. Das geht eigentlich sehr einfach. Naja, und dann ist der Server nach 10-20 Minuten wieder online gegangen. Da hatte ich die auch wieder angetwittert, auch beim ersten Mal schon. Hier Leute, das Problem ist nicht behoben. Und dann ist der Server nach einer guten Stunde wieder offline gegangen, wie die gesamte restliche Esatos. Also ich hab jetzt heute noch nicht geschaut, aber gestern war der gesamte Laden noch irgendwie komplett offline. Und überhaupt hat man irgendwie nichts von denen in der Zwischenzeit gehört.
Heute ist der 8.10. wo wir die Sendung aufnehmen. Gestern war der 7.10. wann ist das passiert?
Das war am Samstag vor der Wahl.
Am Samstag vor der Wahl. Ich muss kurz meinen Kalender aufrufen, weil das ist schon unendlich weit weg in meinem Kopf. Das war also der 25. September. Also seit fast zwei Wochen ist ein System, was dafür gedacht war, unsere aller Identitäten zu verwalten, offline, weil jemand draufgeguckt hat. Ich will es mal diplomatisch formulieren, das ist interessant.
Mittlerweile haben sie das DNS umgezogen zu einem anderen Anbieter und machen das nicht mehr selber. Es sind auch nicht alle Infrastrukturkomponenten offline gegangen, aber die Webseite von denen immer noch nicht verfügbar ist, ist schon interessant.
Aber die App funktioniert auch nach wie vor nicht?
Das weiß ich gerade gar nicht. Ich hab da nicht mehr drauf geschaut. Lilith meinte, glaube ich, dass sie wieder funktioniert, mit der ID Wallet App. Aber ich hab jetzt noch nicht drauf geschaut. Sollte ich vielleicht mehr machen, weil dann können wir da auch noch die letzten Leute, die sich beschweren, dass wir die Lizzi App, die technologisch genau das gleiche ist wie die ID Wallet App, dass wir die benutzen und nicht die ID Wallet App zufriedenstellen, indem wir das noch mal mit der ID Wallet App vorführen.
Es gibt also mehrere Apps, die das umsetzen, und die haben aber alle dasselbe Problem?
Also die haben alle ganz unterschiedliche Probleme und funktionieren alle mehr oder weniger gut. Ich meine, ihr habt es alle gesehen, wie die App halt immer wieder gecrashed ist. Die Lizzy Wallet ist schon ein bisschen besser. Also die fand ich eigentlich ganz gut. Und die implementieren alle den gleichen Standard halt. Also es gibt eine Protokollspezifikation oder halt überhaupt irgendwie eine Spezifikation zu diesen decentralized identities. Und die wird von unterschiedlichen Wallets implementiert. Dann war alles offline. Und dann habe ich geschaut, so was kann man noch an Infrastruktur erreichen. Weil ich wollte mich immer noch nicht an dem Punkt irgendwie mit Blockchain beschäftigen. Und dann hat man noch geguckt, was ist noch irgendwie an Infrastruktur verfügbar. Die Blockchain lief irgendwie so auf eine Handvoll, ich glaube sieben Stück waren sieben Servern. Und dann habe ich mir dieses Server mal angeschaut. Da waren nämlich noch einige von erreichbar. Und da hatte ich auf einen gesehen, dass der Log-Files ins Internet liegt, dass er metriken. Also es gibt so in der Informatik oder in der IT-Operation, es gibt so Monitoring. Das heißt, man guckt irgendwie auch so Server-Computersysteme drauf. Wie laufen die? Wie performen die? Und das war halt Richtung Internet exponiert. Und man konnte sich da irgendwelche Log-Files anschauen von so einem Server, auf dem die Blockchain halt läuft. Und das Interessante ist...
Liebe Hörer, an dieser Stelle kurz einmal, wir sprechen gleich noch ein bisschen ausführlicher über die Blockchain. Ich lasse das gerade laufen, weil ich glaube, es gibt zu viele Ansatzpunkte. Wir sprechen aber gleich noch über Blockchain. Okay, es gibt also die Log-Files und die kann man im Internet lesen.
Ja, genau. Also man konnte da irgendwelche Log-Files lesen. Und es stand da aber auch jetzt nicht so viel Interessantes drin. Man hat irgendwelche Nachrichten von dem Blockchain-Service, der da läuft. Ja, und man konnte auch eigene Getrigen pushen. Das heißt, man konnte da irgendwie in deren Monitoring-System eigene numerische Werte für irgendwelche Counter oder so halt irgendwie reinpacken. Auch jetzt nicht super kritisch, aber halt auch irgendwie unschön. Also das ist halt irgendwie unsauber. Dann haben Lilith und ich uns mal die App vorgeknüpft, beziehungsweise genauer das Protokoll. Und haben da drin eine Schwachstelle gefunden. Und haben jetzt viel über Identitäten gesprochen und auch irgendwie festgestellt, dass die sauber identifiziert werden, sichergestellt werden, dass irgendwie nicht vorgegeben, irgendwie Fluepke zu sein, dass ich auch Fluepke bin. Aber was die Macherinnen von dieser App oder diesem gesamten Standard da irgendwie vergessen haben, ist, na ja, vergessen ist auch ein bisschen vielleicht schon freundliche Unterstellung, kann ich gleich noch mal drauf eingehen, vergessen haben, ist, dass mein Gegenüber überhaupt nicht identifiziert ist. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo in eine Polizeikontrolle oder so was komme, da irgendwie meinen Führerschein vorzeige, dann bekomme ich auf meinem Telefon an, die Polizei will sich jetzt hier mit dir connecten. Und an der Stelle ist überhaupt nicht sichergestellt, dass es tatsächlich die Polizei ist. Sondern das könnte halt doch jeder andere sein.
Wie muss ich mir das gar nicht praktisch vorstellen? Scann ich da ein QR-Code oder wie findet dieses Auslesen statt?
Das Auslesen funktioniert so, genau, dass du ein QR-Code scannst. Dann bekommst du zunächst eine Anfrage hier, der und der oder die und die will sich verbinden, gibt es auf der ID-Wallet-App auch noch ein hübsches Foto dazu. Wir haben ja auch gepostet hier mit Helge Braun, wants to connect. Und dann kannst du da entweder das annehmen oder ablehnen. So in der Polizeikontrolle würdest du das dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie eher annehmen. Und dann bekommst du, wenn du diese Verbindung akzeptiert hast, eine Anfrage darüber, welche Daten du freigeben möchtest, an die Polizei zum Beispiel oder an irgendein Hotel, wo du gerade einen checkst. Und ja, da gibt es dann zwei Buttons annehmen, annehmen oder ablehnen. Und wenn du darauf annehmen drückst, dann werden die Daten übermittelt an deinem Gegenüber. Und dein Gegenüber kann dann irgendwie verifizieren, sind diese Daten echt, habe ich es da tatsächlich irgendwie mit Fluepke zu tun? Und was sind die anderen Datenfelder, die Fluepke irgendwie freigegeben hat? Darf der eigentlich überhaupt ein Auto fahren?
Das kann jetzt sozusagen aber einfach jeder. Also ich ziehe mir sozusagen eine grüne Uniform an und generiere einen QR-Code, der zum System passt. Und da fehlt dann irgendwie die Überprüfung, ob ich überhaupt eine staatliche Stelle bin oder einfach nur ein Typ, der eine QR-Code generiert hat.
Richtig, wobei das mit der grünen Uniform vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig ist, juristisch.
Schwieriger als ein QR-Code zu generieren, meinst du?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Aber ich bin auch kein Anwalt. Du kannst ja halt letzten Endes einfach einen QR-Code erzeugen, kannst da reinschreiben, ja hallo, guten Tag, ich bin die Polizei. Und denen dann halt irgendjemanden unter die Nase halten. Und die angegriffene Person kann dann nicht unterscheiden zwischen ist das jetzt wirklich die Polizei, die da anfragt oder nicht. In einer Polizeikontrollesituation ist das vielleicht noch ein bisschen nachvollziehbarer, weil man kann sich ja einen Ausweis von Polizisten zeigen lassen. So in der Hotelchecking-Situation ist das natürlich ein bisschen anders. Da steht halt irgendwo so ein QR-Code in so einem Hotel rum, den kann man einfach überkleben. Vielleicht auch noch in einem teuren Hotel, dann kann man vielleicht irgendwie ein paar interessante Daten von irgendwelchen reichen Leuten, die da in so einem teuren Hotel einchecken, stibbitzen. Und da ist halt weniger Kontext drumherum, wo man dann irgendwie sicherstellen kann, ob dieser QR-Code jetzt gerade echt ist oder ob der falsch ist.
Und der sozusagen, diese Intität des Kontrolleurs, der Kontrolleur nicht, der Anleger, die kann ich auch völlig freigestalten. Also sie, um mit deinem Beispiel zu bleiben, auch exakt so aussehen lassen, als wäre ich das Luxushotel.
Richtig, also das wäre, in der Lisi Wallet App wird bei dem, was wir jetzt gerade vorführen, nur von einer Direct Connection gesprochen. Aber da hast du natürlich gar keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie zu unterscheiden. Ist jetzt eine Direct Connection irgendwie valide? Es erscheint auch in diesem blauen Haken daneben. Das sieht erstmal alles irgendwie gut aus. Das hat damit zu tun, dass es in diesem gesamten Konzept mehrere Verfahren gibt, wie man jetzt irgendwie eine Verbindung zwischen dem Hotel und dir irgendwie aufbauen kann. Und was wir implementiert haben, ist die Direct Connection. In der Lisi Wallet App wird die als Direct Connection dargestellt. In der ID Wallet App wird die mit einem hübschen Logo und einem Namen daneben dargestellt.
Jetzt muss ich aber doch nochmal fragen, weil du immer zwischen Lisi App und ID Wallet App unterscheidest, ist die Firma, die du genannt hast, die EsatOS, die ist aber für die Infrastruktur, die beide benutzen, zuständig? Oder wie hängt das zusammen? Das ist mir noch nicht ganz klar.
Die Infrastruktur wird von ganz unterschiedlichen Parteien betrieben. Also die Blockchain läuft auf Instanzen, die zu einem größeren Konsortium angehören, die da halt irgendwie Computer für das ganze Ding zur Verfügung stellen. Es gibt aber auch einige Komponenten, die werden von der ESATOS betrieben. Zum Beispiel, obwohl das alles ja so toll dezentral angeblich ist, gibt es da eine sehr zentrale Infrastruktur Komponente, die gerüchtenzufolge wohl auch nie unter Last getestet wurde und viel zu klein dimensioniert wurde. Das ist so ein Mediator. Der wird zum Beispiel von der ESATOS betrieben, wenn mich nichts täuscht.
Was macht der? Was macht ein Mediator?
Der Mediator ist so eine Art Message Broker, sowas wie MQTT, könnte man sich vielleicht vorstellen. Der sorgt dafür, dass zwei Parteien, die sich in ganz unterschiedlichen Netzwerksituationen befinden, miteinander eine Verbindung aufbauen können. Das ist quasi so ein Router für Nachrichten, die sich in diesem System zugestellt werden. Und das ist halt nicht sehr dezentral.
Das ist auch Teil des Systems, wo man in das DNS reingucken kann?
Genau, den konnte man auch im DNS sehen, was ich da publiziert hatte. Ganz so dezentral ist es schon mal nicht, wie sie vergeben.
Jetzt noch mal die Frage, das Hauptproblem. Ich habe es so verstanden, alles, was wir bisher gelernt haben, ist vor allen Dingen so, dass man denkt, das ist nicht kritisch für den konkreten Anwendungsfall, aber nicht schön, wie ihr das macht, aber jetzt dieses mit. Eigentlich kann jeder deine Daten angucken, wenn er es nur schafft, dir den QR-Code zu unterjubeln. Das ist der erste konkrete Angriffspunkt. Ist das ein Problem der Apps oder ist das ein Problem des Konzepts? Also könnte man juristisch, technisch gesagt sagen, die Apps sind sauber programmiert, das System gibt es einfach gar nicht her.
Lilith und ich haben da sehr genau auf die Standards draufgeschaut und haben nicht wirklich gesehen, dass es irgendwo spezifiziert sei, dass auch der dein Gegenüber verifiziert wird. Dieses Problem, was Lilith und ich da vorführen, ist halt, wie gesagt, eine Spezifikation und nicht in den Apps. Die Apps sind so gesehen korrekt nach der Spezifikation implementiert. Und die Leute, die diese Spezifikation designen, die wissen von dem Problem. Also das ist ein bekanntes Problem. Da gab es GitHub-Issues zu und die wurden dann zugemacht mit irgendwie Won'tfix. Und um dieses Problem muss man sich irgendwie auf einem höheren Layer kümmern. Und dazu gab es auch auf der Mailing-Liste einiges an Diskussionen. Da kann man sich auch öffentlich anschauen von dieser Spezifikation. Und ja, also man kann nicht sagen, dass sie das nicht gewusst hätten, was da abgeht. Und ich meine, wenn man jetzt irgendwie als Start so eine Identity-Lösung einführt, dann sollte man sich auch irgendwie sowas mal anschauen oder zumindest gesehen haben und sich dazu Gedanken gemacht haben.
Das klingt für mich zumindest sehr plausibel, wenn du das vorlässt. Okay, sind wir damit am Ende der Timeline gegentreten angekommen?
Basically yes. Also ich meine, seitdem ist da eigentlich nicht mehr viel passiert. Außer, dass es noch ein politisches Echo dazu gab. Scheuer zeigte sich zum Beispiel Stocksauer. Und das gehe eben irgendwie auf den Zeiger. Das ist Projekte, die er richtig korrekt implementiert hat. Irgendwie dann an irgendwelchen Zuständigkeiten oder sowas scheitern. Und da muss man ihm zugutehalten, dass es sogar durchaus sein kann, dass sein Kraftfahrtbundesamt, dass das Kraftfahrtbundesamt die Schnittstellen und so weiter korrekt implementiert hat. Das kann durchaus sein. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem irgendwie noteworthy, dass sich Scheuer Stocksauer zeigt. Aber sonst ist nicht mehr viel passiert.
Aber das heißt sozusagen Stand heute ist auch, man muss eigentlich davon abraten, diese Apps zu benutzen, solange diese Lücke in der Spezifikation, nicht in der konkreten App, in der Spezifikation nicht gefixt ist, oder?
Richtig. Und deswegen glaube ich auch nicht, dass die App, Sie haben ja angekündigt, in wenigen Wochen schon wieder online gehen zu wollen. Und deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass es so schnell passieren wird. Weil man wird dann in den entsprechenden Konsortien, Ditcom, V1, was sie da verwenden, ist ja auch schon veraltet. Dann wird man erst mal Ditcom V2 implementieren müssen. Dann wird man sich da weiter Gedanken dazu machen müssen, wie man irgendwie solche Angriffe verhindert. Und das wird natürlich einiges an Zeit in Anspruch nehmen. Und ja, was halt auch lustig ist, ist, dass was dahinter herbei rumkommt, ist eine technische Lösung, die haben wir heute schon, und die nennt sich TLS. So, und vielleicht hast du es auch gemerkt, wir haben bisher überhaupt nicht über die Blockchain gesprochen.
Das habe ich gemerkt, das habe ich mir natürlich aufgehoben. Also TLS ist ja einfach, also einfach in Anführungszeichen, aber das ist einfach ein Standard für verschüsselte Kommunikation im Internet. Aber ich bin noch an einem kleinen Punkt verwirrt, und zwar du sagst einerseits, die App ist wieder da, und andererseits sagst du, das System ist offline. Kannst du noch mal ein bisschen auseinanderklamüsern, was genau das meint?
Ja, die EsatOS hat natürlich irgendwie so einen eigenen IP-Space. Das sind irgendwie so 2048 IP-Adressen. Die haben sie von der Telekom bekommen, um da drin halt irgendwie ihre ganze Infrastruktur, sowas man so als Unternehmen irgendwie so braucht, zu betreiben. Und davon unabhängig gibt es noch irgendwie App-Infrastruktur, und die App ist jetzt scheinbar, wie gesagt, ich hab noch nicht reingeschaut, wieder verfügbar. Also zumindest funktioniert sie wieder. Was irgendwie dafür spricht, dass bestimmte Backend-Teile wieder hochgefahren wurden. Aber de facto ist die ID Wallet-App gerade auch noch aus den App-Stores entfernt.
Okay, also für mich, also wir haben jetzt technisch irgendwie auch sehr, du hast es sehr differentiert dargestellt, aber für mich klingt das, nach ein weiteres Projekt aus dem Hause Scheuer ist krachend gescheitert.
Ist ja nicht nur Scheuer, aber halt mehrere.
Ja, ja, das stimmt. Aber es ist eben auch Scheuer.
Herz angezündet.
Genau. So, genau. Und jetzt ist zwischendurch immer Blockchain so gekommen. Jetzt brauchen wir doch noch mal, um drüber sprechen zu können, eine kleine Definition. Lass mich jetzt versuchen, sag mal, ob ich falsch gehe. Also Blockchain ist im Prinzip die Idee, dass wenn eine Transaktion stattfindet, dass eine Aufgabe gelöst wird, eine mathematische Aufgabe mehr oder weniger, und dann wird diese Transaktion in ein Buch reingeschrieben. Und das macht aber nicht nur ein, es gibt nicht ein zentrales Buch, sondern das machen ganz viele Parteien. Und wenn ganz viele Parteien gesagt haben, ja, wir haben diese Transaktion auch in unser Buch geschrieben, dann gilt die als Realität. Dann ist sie sozusagen passiert. Ist das in der Kneppe und Kürze richtig zusammengefasst?
Also vielleicht noch eins, das Hauptverteidigungsargument der Esaturs war ja immer, das ist keine Blockchain, das ist ein distributed ledger.
Okay, was ist der Unterschied? Ich dachte mal, das eine ist ein Fachwort für das andere.
Konkret ist eine Blockchain sozusagen eine Ausprägung davon. Und im Detail ist es so, dass das einfach mathematische Konzepte aus den 50er Jahren sind. Lange bevor wir öffentliche Schlüsselkanten, also Public Key Cryptography, und damit also so was wie RSA oder Elliptic Curve und damit Signaturen und somit auch Zertifikatsketten erstellen konnten.
CK, du bist selber schuld, dass du das alles gesagt hast. Jetzt musst du es auch ganz kurz erklären, weil du kannst, also das Problem ist einfach, du hast quasi die eine Sache mit einer anderen Sache erklärt, aber wenn man die nicht weiß, ist man glaube ich trotzdem noch verloren.
Am besten stellst du einfach Fragen. Vielleicht kurz, was die Blockchain ist, du hast das ja schon angerissen.
Weil du es jetzt gerade verglichen hast mit Public Key Infrastructure und Zertifikatskette, dann versuche ich es auch an dieser Stelle nochmal. Es gibt etwas, das heißt asynchrone Verschlüsselungen. Das heißt, dass es einen privaten Teil gibt, mit dem kann man Sachen verschlüsseln, es gibt einen öffentlichen Teil und dann kann man hin und her machen. Wenn ich mit meinem privaten Schlüssel etwas verschlüsselte, kann jemand anders gucken, wenn es mit dem öffentlichen Teil entschlüsselt, ist das wirklich von mir. Umgedreht, wenn jemand etwas mit dem öffentlichen Teil verschlüsselt, kann es nur noch mit dem privaten Teil verschlüsselt werden. Das heißt, nur ich kann es lesen. Und daraus kann man Zertifikate generieren, also verschiedene Institutionen haben öffentliche und private Schlüssel. Und wann immer das Signieren oder Zertifizieren funktioniert, kann man das nachprüfen. Das Problem ist immer, deswegen kommt man dann zu einer Zertifikatskette, wenn Lieschen Müller sagt, ich bin Lieschen Müller, hier ist meine Signatur, weiß ich, dass Lieschen Müller eine Signatur hat, die korrekt ist. Aber dann gibt es große Institutionen, die gelten als vertrauenswürdig. Darüber kann man auch diskutieren, aber so ist zumindest das Konzept. Wenn die große Institution vertraubare Schlüssel-TM das Zertifikat von Lieschen Müller unterschrieben hat, kann ich dann wiederum sagen, wenn das Zertifikat von Lieschen Müller unterschrieben ist und mathematisch korrekt und von dieser Stelle zertifiziert, dann weiß ich, ich kann dem vertrauen. Das kann man dann über mehrere Schritte machen. Das ist, wie man bis jetzt im Internet Vertrauen hergestellt hat. Wenn ihr in eurem Browser HTTPS steht, ist das ungefähr das, was passiert. Dann sagt nämlich die Webseite, ich habe eine vertrauenswürdige Verschlüsselung. Dass die das sagen kann, liegt daran, dass wiederum so eine große, ich weiß jetzt die Namen nicht, auch da gab es mal einen Skandal. Aber das ist ganz kurz zusammengefasst Zertifikatsketten. Das ist das, was wir hatten. Was soll Blockchain slash Distributed Ledger an diesem System besser machen? Oder warum brauchen wir was Neues?
Eigentlich brauchen wir nichts Neues. Das Ding ist irgendwo...
Im Grunde implementieren sie genau das gerade jetzt auf dem Distributed Ledger nach. Wenn sie sagen, wir brauchen jetzt einen Trust Anchor und wir leiten davon signierte Identitäten ab, dann ist es im Grunde genau das. Du hast es ja eben schon richtig festgestellt, wir haben überhaupt nicht über Blockchain gesprochen. Das heißt, die Blockchain hat überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt in diesem Angriff.
Ich bin vor allen Dingen an dem, wo ich gestolpert bin, ist das Konzept von Blockchain das der Dezentralität. Es gibt ganz viele Leute, da stelle ich mir immer so sehr große Zahlen vor, also tausende Teilnehmer an einer Blockchain oder an einem BitSpudger. Jetzt habt ihr gesagt, sieben, verteilt auf sieben Rechner. Und wenn man jetzt konzeptuell drauf guckt, ist das, ist den sieben Rechner dezentral?
Also die sind schon in unterschiedlichen IP-Spaces unter unterschiedlicher Administration. Da kann man doch schon davon sprechen, dass das irgendwie distributed ist. Das würde ich schon sagen. Aber der Punkt ist, dass dieser gesamte distributed Ansatz schon daran scheitert, dass es halt so zentrale Komponenten wie zum Beispiel diesen Mediator gibt, der jetzt irgendwie größer dimensioniert werden muss, bevor man wieder live geht.
Ist das, also auch auf die Gefahr hin, eine rhetorische Frage jetzt zu stellen, ist die Tatsache, dass bei dem ganzen Konzept eine Blockchain benutzt wurde, dem geschuldet, dass die EU gesagt hat, wir finden Blockchain gut, und dass die EU das sagt, weil das gerade irgendwie das digitale Hype-Konzept ist? Oder warum gibt es da Blockchain? Oder ist das so ein Ding von, im Prinzip gibt es einen Anwendungsfall, wo das Sinn macht, der ist noch schlecht umgesetzt?
Leider ist das Nummer eins. Das ist tatsächlich, weil der Hype existiert. Vielleicht ein Gegenbeispiel an der Stelle. Alle kennen inzwischen ja den Impfpass, dieses EU Digital Green Certificate. Und wir hatten ja auch in der ganzen Diskussion auf Twitter schon den Blick in Richtung Führerschein in anderen EU-Staaten. Dass es da auch einen ISO-Norm gibt, zum Beispiel diese ISO 18013-5. Und ich hätte auch schon eingeworfen, dass die Niederländer ja schon damit arbeiten. Und das Konzept dahinter auch bei diesem Impfpass ist, jedes der ungefähr 200 United Nations Länder hat eine sogenannte Country Signing CA. Damit unterschreiben sie auch schon, bisher, seitdem es den elektronischen Reisepass gibt, unabhängig von Biometrie, gibt es schon seit einer Weile länger den Chip, unterschreiben die jeweils auch ihre Pässe damit. Und um das zu koordinieren, gibt es bei der ICAO, das ist die International Civil Aviation Organization, das ist eine UN-Organisation, eine sogenannte CSCA Masterlist. Das heißt also eine Liste aller vertrauenswürdigen oder aktuellen Country seiner CA, aus allen UN-Ländern. Und das heißt, man hat schon eine Infrastruktur, die man auch bei dem Impfpass nutzt, oder auch zum Beispiel bei dem Führerschein nach der ISO-Norm, oder auch beim Reisepass, auch beim Personalschein sogar, die unabhängig voneinander, ohne dass man einen Mediator braucht, oder dass man da irgendeinen Rechner installieren muss, oder dass man eine Blockchain braucht, können die bereits 200 Länder wechselseitig prüfen, ob das Dokument, was jemand präsentiert, tatsächlich echt ist.
Also auch auf die Gefahren mich zu wiederholen, wenn man viele Chaos Rades gehört hat, muss ich fragen, warum?
Warum?
Na gut, das heißt, im Prinzip können wir das Ding zwei Sachen sagen. Einerseits ist es konzeptuell kaputt und zweitens, es ist eine Blockchain drin, die niemand braucht.
So ist es.
Gut. Bleibt eigentlich, glaube ich, nur noch der Ausblick zu erledigen, oder? Also die Frage zu stellen, was müsste man machen, wenn man einen Führerschein und einen Personalausweis und eine selbstsouveräne Identität auf dem Smartphone haben will? Was muss sich ändern?
Da würde ich mal ins Ausland schauen, wie es da funktioniert.
Ja, also wir sind tatsächlich nicht das einzige Land, das solche Dinge überlegt. Und es haben auch ringsrum alle Gerätehersteller verstanden, dass so mit einer App, die da irgendwo läuft, die sich da mal einen Schlüssel ausdenkt und den irgendwie in einem App-Storage speichert, dass das keine gute Idee ist. Weil auch so ein Backup und so bedeutet ja, dass dann die Identität irgendwo anders hingeht. Und da hat zum Beispiel Google auch angefangen, mal zu reagieren. Es gibt seit Mai die Android Secure Element Ready Alliance. Das heißt, Google hat den Herstellern gesagt, Leute, passt auf, in allen zukünftigen Geräten solltet ihr so ein Secure Element verbauen, damit ihr einfach auf die Herausforderungen reagieren könnt, die jetzt gerade kommen. Apple an der Stelle hat ja auch schon seit langem Secure Elements drin, da ist ja auch der Fingerprint Scanner mitgekoppelt, das ist immer dieser schöne Fehler, der da kommt, wenn man die Spider App deinstallieren will, also sprich das Display austauschen muss und dann heißt es ja, die Kopplung ist fehlgeschlagen, da beschwert sich unter anderem auch der Secure Element. Und das ist also auch schon vorhanden. Und Apple hat da auch schon signalisiert, das sieht man auch so an diversen Patentanträgen, die sie gestellt haben, dass sie sich genau das angucken und dass sie auch die Spezifikationen dieser internationalen Norm, das heißt also eine ISO und auch eine ETSI, auch eine UN etc. auf was sie sich geeinigt haben, auch implementieren. Das heißt sogar eine Apple macht standardkonform mit, das ist also für meine Begriffe schon echt eine tolle Aktion. So, Google ist auch dahinter und baut das ein, die haben zum Beispiel auch für die Führerscheine schon eine andere, diese ISO 18013 eingebaut. Das heißt also, wir werden in absehbarer Zeit in den neueren Geräten natürlich oder mit Systemupdates, soweit es geht. Weil Samsung wäre das ab dem Galaxy S7, glaube ich, der Fall, dass man das machen kann. Dann kann ich Secure Elements benutzen. Eine andere Variante ist, ich kann das auf SIM-Karten packen oder auch in eSIM-Profile. Da ist mit den MNOs, also sprich mit den Mobilfunkunternehmen geredet worden auch. Und man hat das aber alles wieder gekippt, wenn man gesagt hat, ja, da läuft ja keine Blockchain drauf. Also Blockchain hat halt auch esoterische Kryptographie. Ich hatte ja auf Twitter auch gesagt, so beim Thema Zero-Knowledge-Proof-Signaturen. Zero-Knowledge-Proof ist gleich Beweisen, dass man gar keine Ahnung hat. Also die Idee ist eigentlich bei dem Zero-Knowledge-Proof, dass du so wenig wie möglich verrätst über deinen Schlüssel, wenn du halt eine Signatur durchführst. Und das sind aber recht interessante Konzepte, die da verwendet werden. Zum einen gibt es so ähnliche Mechanismen bereits mit seriöser Kryptographie. Wo man sich also schon lange Gedanken gemacht hat, wie kriege ich das hin, dass die Signatur verifizierbar war, ohne aber zum Beispiel bei einer zu großen Menge an Signaturen, weil ich ganz viel signiert habe oder Schlüssel vereinbart habe, wie auch immer, also Operationen mit anderen durchgeführt habe im Bereich Public Key Kryptographie. Könnte jetzt jemand anfangen, anhand dessen, was da errechnet worden ist, zu erraten, wie meine Schlüsselpits aussehen? Das kennt man, das ist ein altes Problem. Dazu gab es halt seriöse Lösungen. Es gab dieses Thema mit dem Serial Knowledge Proof. Wenn man sich das Verfahren anguckt, was auch bei dem ganzen ID-Wallet-Thema kam, das ist ein Verfahren, das wirft uns zurück auf das Sicherheitsniveau von RSA 2048.
Das ist eine Möglichkeit, eine asynchrone Verschlüsselung zu machen, die aber kaputt ist, mathematisch, oder wie war das?
Asymetrisch sollten wir sagen, um uns Kritik zu erwehren. Asymetrisch ist der korrekte Begriff. RSA 2048 wird nicht mehr als sicher angesehen. Es steht noch in den BSI-Kryptokatalogen drin. Das ist die technische Richtlinie 021.02. Ich glaube, da ist es noch bis 2022, 2023 irgendwie zugelassen. Und dann aber auch nicht mehr. Das BSI hat aber auch schon gesagt, dass sie die Verfahren früher zurückziehen können, wenn z.B. im Bereich Quantencomputing an der Stelle Fortschritte gemacht werden, die es halt als notwendig erscheinen lassen, Verfahren früher schon als unsicher einzustufen. Das heißt, das ist so kurz vorm, na ja... Warte mal, warte mal.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir begeben uns gerade so an den Rabbit Hole. Der Punkt, den du machen willst, ist im Prinzip, es gibt in, sozusagen, wenn wir über diese ganzen Dinge reden, was Kryptografie und Zertifizierung angeht, gibt es schon jede Menge Diskussionen, mit denen man zu kämpfen hat. Und Blockchain klärt daran überhaupt gar nichts.
Ganz unabhängig von den eingesetzten kryptografischen Systemen muss man auch festhalten, dass der Code echt nicht schön war. Also wir haben da in vielen Stellen keine Tests gesehen. Es war alles irgendwie sehr schnell zusammengeschraubt, macht das den Eindruck.
Keine Tests meint in dem Fall, dass die Software nicht kontrolliert, ob die eingegebenen Daten oder die ankommende Daten korrekt sind.
Das auch. Also wenn der Server mit einem 503 geantwortet hat oder mit einem 500, dann ist die App gecrasht. Aber was ich hier meine ist, dass man automatisch die Korrektheit der App prüft. So in CI zum Beispiel, so Continuous Integration. Da gibt es halt so Unit Tests, die führt man so durch gegen die Software, um zu gucken, funktionieren die Komponenten so, wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben und das fehlte da an vielen Stellen.
Also dass man feststellen kann, ob die Software die ist, die sie sein soll und nicht ausgetauscht wurde oder kaputt?
Das ist nochmal wieder was anderes. Da geht es jetzt einfach nur erst mal darum zu prüfen, dass die Funktionalität der Software überhaupt gegeben ist. Da geht es jetzt nicht darum, kryptographisch die Integrität sicherzustellen, sondern erst mal nur zu gucken, so als Qualitätssicherungsmaßnahme funktioniert die App überhaupt. Und das erklärt wahrscheinlich auch, warum die so fürchterlich nicht funktioniert hat, neben den ganzen anderen Sachen wie Überlastung oder dass sie Reserver runtergefahren haben.
Also das Bild, was ich von dieser, ich nenne es jetzt mal Lösung, also das Bild, was ich von dieser Lösung habe, ist das eines Autos, wo man die Motorhaube aufmacht und dann sieht, also statt Motor ist da so ein Hamster in seinem Hamsterrad, der das Ganze antreiben soll, was echt hart wird, weil, naja, da ist schon irgendwie, also da muss schon viel bewegt werden. Das ist sozusagen das Hauptproblem. Aber wenn man um das Auto drumrum geht und sich anguckt, dann ist das eigentlich auch so sehr rostig. Und die Stellen, die stimmen alle nicht. Und die Schrauben sind nicht fest. Und das, naja, ist eigentlich...
Da frage ich mich bei dem Autovergleich ja auch, wieso hat man da nicht einen Kfz-Meister mal draufschauen lassen? Wir haben solche Leute, wir haben halt das BSI. Warum haben die da nicht mehr draufgeschaut und gesagt, halt, stopp, so nicht? Weil das sind halt alles Sachen, die sind eigentlich relativ offensichtlich, wenn man sich damit beschäftigt mit solchen Technologien. Und Lilith und ich haben auch nicht lange gebraucht, irgendwie, um auf die Idee zu kommen, oh, da ist ein QR-Code. Vielleicht könnte man den QR-Code ja irgendwie austauschen, um irgendwie an Identitäten dran zu kommen. Wir haben dann allerdings so anderthalb, zwei Tage gebraucht, uns durch diese schlechtgeschriebene Software und die schlechtgeschriebenen Standards durchzulesen, um tatsächlich so eine Minimalanwendung mal zu implementieren. Und man sollte vielleicht noch dazu sagen, ich habe vorher, bevor ich jetzt in IT-Security arbeite, habe ich als Network-Engineer gearbeitet und als solcher natürlich auch immer mal wieder so Internetstandards gelesen, solche Spezifikationen und daraus Implementationen gebaut. Und das ist halt das, was hier irgendwie abgeliefert wurde, ist irgendwie nicht schön. Und soweit ich weiß, hat Mozilla jetzt auch gerade abgelehnt, dass dieser Standard, also diese Spezifikation zu Decentralized Identities, dass der zum Proposed-Standard wird hat oder irgendwie eine Stufe weitergeht und irgendwie, ja, da gibt's jetzt so eine Timeline, wie irgendwie solche Standards entwickelt werden und dann irgendwie publiziert werden. Und da hat Mozilla gesagt, so halt stopp, das geht jetzt erst mal in den Anfangsstatus zurück. Wir finden das irgendwie nicht gut. Microsoft findet das irgendwie nicht gut, Google findet das nicht gut. Und da ist jetzt gerade irgendwie auch sehr viel Diskussion am Gange irgendwie um dieses ganze Decentralized Identity Ding.
Okay, also da wird noch eine Zeit ins Land gehen, bevor das wirklich funktioniert. Ich hätte noch eine letzte Frage, Fluepke. Und das ist, jetzt ist es ja so, wenn man sich Dinge öffentlicher Stellen anguckt, dann reagieren die ja manchmal nicht mit vielen lieben Dank, dass sie die Arbeit gemacht haben, für die wir eigentlich hätten teuer jemand bezahlen müssen. Wir werden das sofort bessern. Sondern das kippt ja manchmal ins Gegenteil. Man kriegt dann Strafanzeigen oder so Dinge ins Haus. Ist euch da irgendwas Negatives widerfahren nach der Veröffentlichung? Also außer das, was du erzählt hast, dass sie komplett ignoriert haben, was ihr gesagt habt?
Ja, also wir wurden da erstmal ignoriert. Dann wurden wir in einem Dokument des Herstellers und des Bundeskanzleramts beleidigt, als eine politisch motivierte Zusammenrottung mit Hacking-Affinität und dem Ziel, eine negative Öffentlichkeit zu erzielen für das Ding. Also der Hersteller, keine Ahnung, ist da irgendwie nicht auf Augenhöhe unterwegs. Dann gibt es von einzelnen Menschen aus dieser SSI Community, die versuchen einen einzuschüchtern oder öffentlich zu verleumden. Das sind aber einzelne Personen. Ansonsten ist bisher nichts Schlimmes, nichts Böses passiert. Ich sitze hier noch in meiner Wohnung, die bisher noch nicht geradet wurde. Aber so eine Strafanzeige, die dauert natürlich auch ein bisschen. Von daher ist es, denke ich, am jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch zu früh darüber zu sprechen, ob da dann noch was kommt. Dass es keine Reaktion von keiner der Gegenseiten gab, spricht schon mal eher dafür, dass man nicht an einem Diskurs interessiert ist. Und dass da eventuell auch noch was zu befürchten ist.
Drücke euch auf jeden Fall die Daumen, dass das nicht passiert. Vielen Dank, CK, vielen Dank Fluepke, dass ihr heute da wart und geduldig Ertragen habt, wie ich immer wieder unterbreche, wie ich versuche zu erklären, was da genau passiert ist. Aber ich hoffe, es hat dazu beigetragen, dass man jetzt verstehen kann, was da genau passiert ist. Warum das ID Wallet und die ganzen ähnlichen Lösungen in ihrer derzeitigen Form momentan eher ein Problem sind als eine Lösung. Ihr, liebe Hörerinnen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn es euch gefallen hat, tragt uns weiter oder kommentiert fleißig. Ansonsten habe ich heute nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, und das ist, wie immer, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.